14 heures nicolas sarkozy arrive à la
mairie de belfort
c'est le dernier rendez vous inscrit à
son programme et il est important
puisqu'il s'agit de sa rencontre avec
les syndicats de general electric
ici c'est vraiment ce triel où il ya un
savoir faire exceptionnel
ça a mis des décennies à se constituer
c'est difficile de laisser tomber il
faut que généralité ils disent aussi la
réalité de leurs intentions
l'entrevue s'est déroulée en présence
des élus locaux et loin des caméras
au premier étage de l'hôtel de ville 45
minutes durant lesquelles les
organisations syndicales ont tenté de
recueillir l'aide et les précieux
conseils de l'ancien chef de l'état
alors que l'actuel a refusé de les
rencontrer lundi dernier à ornans
monsieur le président nous a dit de
mettre le couteau sous la gorge de
general electric pour obtenir réellement
leur attention
il a pris l'engagement de contacter
bruno le maire il a déjà eu un échange
avant notre rencontre il aura un échange
après il a pris l'engagement aussi de
rencontrer monsieur macron et de nous
aider du mieux qu'ils pouvaient 15h fin
de la réunion
nicolas sarkozy reprend la route pour
paris et les syndicats poursuivent leur
combat contre le plan de licenciement
dont les négociations débutent dans
quelques jours